so you think america is going to vote in
the rock
you hope so yes or no
yeah no guys about the
iraq would be the best candidate rock
for president
thank you very much thank you guys thank
you man so
corona situation here in budapest
not too many people are worried that's
the feeling i'm getting is that right
yeah yep pretty much pretty chill you
don't have to
wear masks anywhere except the stores
and
public transportation nobody is going to
uh
i mean tell you that you should wear a
mask or anything because they are
they also do not care about it thinking
about anymore probably
don't even believe that this thing
exists thank you very much video is okay
guys
it's okay no problem peace have a good
one high five
see you over there
alright guys here in budapest hungary
and i want to preface this video by
saying this is not a place
for objective data anything
scientific this is a video about
what the corona situation is like on the
streets of budapest
at this very moment in time so i'm here
because i have to get my ukrainian
residency permit renewed
and you have to leave the country get
this you have to leave the country to do
it at a foreign consulate
interesting i thought i honestly thought
coming from ukraine it would be way
tighter here
uh way more restricted because it's the
eu
it's more of a developed country but
it's actually the opposite
the day after i got here i got an email
saying
your return flight has been canceled so
while things are locking down in certain
ways
well it doesn't feel like it on the
streets that's for sure
beautiful architecture in this city
really a
very interesting mix
it was the second capital of the
austrian hungarian
empire and they did build beauty that's
for sure
so americans cannot come here right now
to the eu
at all so you'll find
no americans on these streets and you'll
find pretty much
no tourists on these streets
all right i'm not gonna act like i know
budapest well at all
because it was i believe it's 2003 i was
here last
do you remember how cool of a city it is
here we got some skaters
this guy number one tony hawk i was the
first in
hungary the number one skateboarding
generation
you guys are all over 40 years old yeah
probably he's
over 45
[Music]
45
what's up with the coronavirus here
people don't worry no problem
it's over it's over it's over
before the virus is only a people's mind
yeah because it feels like life is
normal here it's not the future it's
just a normal flu so
yeah that's that's my opinion but yeah i
have no idea what we're doing
honestly exactly as far as the corona
situation
i gotta say i have no idea what's going
on i think most of us
don't have a good grasp of what's going
on and it's interesting when you
cross country borders and the psychology
changes a bit and then you adapt
to where you're at so
here i've adapted i'm not going to be
the only guy wearing a mask out here
right now
but check out this situation this place
is going off
it's festive it's alive i haven't felt
this
i haven't felt anything like this for
well since last summer
you're from greenland what's your name
by the way um
we honestly have a dentist name
you're from greenland what are you doing
here i am a traveller
you've been traveling everywhere have
you been to um
like cambodia yeah have you seen that
waters like uh the trains yes
when they say new moon yes the color
change yeah so you are traveling
yourself
yes
[Applause]
here in a different neighborhood a
little bit of a younger crowd
some cheap eating options
and the spar let's see what it looks
like in the spar
okay so some people are wearing masks
some people are not wearing masks
so not enforced that's for sure
i want to reiterate the fact that i just
got here
i don't live here i don't know the ins
and outs of the place
this looks more like a late night
party area we have the spot greja
and this is what you always see in
budapest around every corner
something like that
it's one of those cities you can just
breathe it in
calms the mind it's
inspirational
all right guys getting hungry here gonna
get some food at a great restaurant
i'll show you i've been there the last
two nights
excellent food but i want to talk about
one thing first
and that is the one guy i talked to
about kobit today on the streets the
skater guy
who said it was bs that's his opinion
and as a content creator
this is the crazy part um you know there
could have been another person that said
they were very worried and they thought
it was a huge issue
and i could leave that information out
so
the power that the creator has to tell
the story
is something that everyone should be
very aware of i'm sure most of my
audience is
but whatever information you're watching
online right now
i could cut this place as cut the story
mean edit the story as a very uh
very strict place with covet i could
show the masks of people on the buses
uh the few people i saw on the street
with masks and then find a person that
says they're extremely worried and that
could be my story or i could show the
story
uh well that i naturally came into today
so i try my best to give
the fair full non-biased story
and that's what i came into so maybe
we'll see something different gonna go
to the restaurant
show you a cool street up here here it
is guys babka
it's a nice middle eastern fusion food
met the chef
uh the last two nights very cool guy who
knows how to run a business
friendly staff excellent food they know
what they're doing
so here's what it inside inside looks
like
see y'all
yeah it's okay uh here
[Music]
it was too loud to talk in there so i
want to finish this video by saying
again this is not a scientific survey of
what's going on in hungary or budapest
but there you go that's what it's like
on the streets
so it feels like normality
for the first time in a long time be
interesting to see how this stuff all
plays out
every country is doing a different thing
and what will those final
results be uh
hold on one second i want to show you
this meal
i'm gonna have one of the best meals
i've had in a long
time
[Music]
egg cauliflower tomatoes
nuts oil fantastic
[Music]